well around the world higher
temperatures extreme weather events and
melting ice caps now popular ice cream
flavors apparently endangered yeah this
is all because of the raw ingredients
that are used in ice cream and they're
becoming harder to grow as the world
gets hotter elise preston has the full
report
it's chocolate chip cookie dough day
inside the factory where ben jerry's
makes its ice cream bite size chunks of
frozen cookie dough get added followed
by chocolate chips but climate change is
threatening this popular ice cream pint
and many others all of these flavors in
the cup are endangered they are because
they've all got cocoa
coffee
vanilla nuts all of these ingredients
are actually now under threat cheryl
pinto is known as the sorceress at ben
and jerry's because she sources all the
raw ingredients she says sustainable
chocolate is getting harder to find 60
percent of the world's chocolate comes
from west africa where poor farmers are
facing the effects of deforestation
eighty ninety percent of the trees are
gone when you start removing the forest
you actually impact the regional weather
patterns researchers forecast 90 percent
of the area in the region currently used
for cocoa cultivation won't be able to
grow the crop by 2050 and the type of
coffee being used in 70 percent of
worldwide coffee production can't
tolerate temperatures over 73 degrees
unfortunately where we grow coffee which
is more towards the equator those areas
are getting affected the most by climate
change plant scientist dr alan van dyne
says farmers will need to adopt new
species of endangered crops i'm an
optimist we're finding varieties that
can take the heat a little better and
some crops are going to thrive more than
others but van dynes and pinto agree new
varieties will taste different and cost
more to grow what we have to do though
is be very aware of where food is coming
in how do we support those farmers she
says in this warmer world consumers
should demand their cold treats are
sourced well elise preston cbs news
waterbury vermont